the movie our friend uh you made
this amongst with some other people you
made this beautiful film
uh i watched it and i watched it alone
i got a link to see the film and i
watched it and it's beautiful and it's
gorgeous and
i'm crying my eyes out at the end which
i don't do
because the irish we don't have emotions
and um or we
we suppress them so much but i i just
walked out of the movie and
that is for me a five-star review
because i thought it was beautifully
done
uh and i thought all the performances
were fantastic and it's such a powerful
story
and it's a true story which i didn't
realize
i mean when i was watching it i didn't
know the back story that this is
a journalist wrote this story it's the
true story of his wife getting ill
and his best friend helping him through
it
and uh it's absolutely gorgeous thanks
so much
uh i really appreciate that um
yeah it's so uh matthew teague lost his
wife to cancer he's a writer and
um this article for edwire and i think
i think that part of it was just
catharsis for him trying to process this
i mean he went through the worst thing
you're gonna go through in life
somehow he came out of the other side of
processing this tragedy
as being able to frame it as a story of
friendship um and that was like
incredibly moving to me i mean that's
the big
thing with life right like how are we
going to construct meaning from these
things that happen to us
um and i just found it uh
kind of really heartbreaking and really
moving i feel really lucky to have been
a part of it
yeah uh dakota johnson is fantastic
in it and um and and casey affleck i
thought was fantastic and
it all feels i mean as it should
it feels very real and it's hard to
explain
but it's harrowing and sad
and then uplifting at the same time and
so
i was the movie's over and i'm crying
and i went and found my wife and i was
just like
hug me please don't ever get sick
but at the same time i
felt better for having seen the movie
and i felt
this great sense of like perspective
does that makes
like it does and i think that part of so
i think it has a couple things that make
it unique our director comes from
documentary
she's made some narratives but she also
directed blackfish and some other really
great documentaries
and so first off she wasn't interested
in it being a melodrama
she wanted to feel like you know real
depiction of what this process might be
like
which like all the great james brooks
movies
you know their life was never one thing
right it's sad and funny and you're
laughing through the hardest parts
um and i thought she did that really
really well
and i think that also she handled the
emotion like a magic trick where there
this humor and and
lightheartedness and friendship is
peppered all the way through
in this way that when when the tragedy
inevitably happens
it it's harder and more emotional
because you've seen
all the good times yes you talk about
the comedy in it
your character is a person who's
struggling to find himself
he can never quite figure out you know
his path in life
and one of the paths he tries to stand
up comedy he's interested in a stand-up
and
i thought well that's really interesting
because there's a part of it where
you're a famously very funny person but
you're very convincing
[Music]
at playing a character who's naturally
funny but trying stand-up but
not polished and not particularly great
at it
and it was i thought a very accurate
portrayal of someone trying it out
thank you it was the most terrifying
part of doing the movie
honestly really i was not afraid at all
of doing the drama because
i was surrounded by great actors and i
felt like if i
let them take the lead and just try to
be honest on camera i'll be okay
i kind of know how to do that at this
point i've never tried stand up
and in the script there's i mean you do
the comedy
you really understand there's some
assumption that someone who does comedy
just
knows how to do all the different stuff
and so in the script it just said
dane does stand up and i i don't
i don't write jokes that way i was
really scared it also had to be mediocre
so i i thought to myself like
what do i do who do i call and i
randomly had
adam sandler's phone number in my phone
because i had congratulated him on
on something he did uh he's made such a
great turn into drama
and i thought oh you know what he's
someone who would understand like i'm
trying to do this drama
maybe he'll be able to help me out so i
texted him like hey i'm so sorry to
bother you this is jason siegel
i'm uh doing a movie where i have to do
stand up do you have any
uh jokes that you might be able to give
me i didn't even know if that was an
appropriate question
right and he was like i i don't off hand
but i have a friend who can send you
some jokes
it's my pleasure i was like oh my god
thank god
and then later that night the jokes
arrived and they were
so dirty they were like
the dirtiest jokes i had ever
read in my life and i was embarrassed
reading them
and i hadn't contextualized enough
this was a cancer drama yeah yeah you
didn't say
by the way it's a cancer drama i'm not
doing uh a roast it's not a roast
of sarah silverman
shut my computer at one point
yeah if you um now that thinking about
the movie if your character had gotten
up there and done that
uh stand up in that context it would
have been it would have just ruined the
film
it would have been horrible yeah yeah
well
uh adam sandler needs to pay for what he
did you know
you know what it was the kindest thing
in the world that you thought
try to send me those jokes
i'll find another concept someday i
don't know
we have a we have a clip here from our
friend
i actually don't know which clip this is
do you yes i believe that this is a clip
where
um the family finally is just completely
overwhelmed and they start they're at
each other's throats and things are
really falling apart at home
so i demand that casey affleck's
character matt t
come with me on a hike because that's
how i that's how i process my grief and
so
this is us uh together yeah i know this
scene well let's take a look at this
clip from our friend
you see that so yeah yes i see them
that's nice
what what's funny to you just did your
hair
i did not did your hair no it didn't it
was windy early
first of all they can't even see us
they're not looking at your hair
second of all it's weird to just sit
over here and watch
so we should have to tell them that
we're here so that they know
so they don't you know go skinny dipping
or something
just say someone's over here so they
know we're here
just say something tell them i'm going
to i'm thinking of what to say
just say there are people here it
doesn't matter what you say
there's people here it doesn't matter
what you say
to this day at my age happily married
uh if i if if i out of the corner of my
eye
see attractive women who aren't even
going to see me
i slightly try and adjust my hair yes
funny that you say it's funny that you
say at your age because i'm now reaching
the point where people who i
feel are my contemporaries are calling
me sir
and i just hate it oh i know it's awful
it's awful
i don't know what happened but wait till
i think i'm uh
i've got some years on you and then some
and um
i think of myself as this young goofy
guy and occasionally someone offers to
help me across the street
that hasn't happened yet but we know
it's coming um
let me make sure i get this the word out
our friend
is out now in theaters and at home on
demand
and uh it's the best movie i've seen in
a while
i mean in memory i really loved it
and um it's it's got everything
it's got everything and very powerful
and your performance all the
performances were great but
i'm really happy for you i'm a huge fan
of yours and so
i did and i knew nothing about this
movie when i saw it i just knew
that you were in it and that you'd be
coming on the show and so i went in
blank slate and was just blown away so
congratulations
thanks man it just means the world to me
i appreciate that